l'arménie et l'azerbaïdjan prête à
l'affrontement généralisée de part et
d'autre ont mobilisé combats ont eu lieu
entre arméniens et azéris dans la région
contestée du karabagh et hier soir à
pâques ou capitale de l'azerbaïdjan des
manifestations ont fait plus d'une
vingtaine de morts dans une boîte de
nuit de saragosse en espagne un incendie
se déclare la fumée qui se dégage
immédiatement des matières plastiques
asphyxie pratiquement sur place en
quelques minutes
43 personnes fini les routiers sympas en
france un sondage établit définitivement
que 60 % des automobilistes ont peur des
poids lourds qui provoque il faut dire
de plus en plus d'accidents mortels 5
m'a le plus grand voilier du monde a été
construit en france aux chantiers du
havre son nom le club med il servira de
villages flottants gentil reportage à la
fin du snobisme
madame monsieur bonsoir l'actualité de
ce dimanche est dominé en partie par un
incendie survenu à saragosse en espagne
une tragédie qui laisse stupéfait
anéantis dans la mesure où elle a fait
43 morts en l'espace de quelques minutes
à peine dans une boîte de nuit la soirée
hier soir bat son plein soudain un court
circuit électrique
le feu se propage immédiatement on peut
lire le mot n'est pas trop fort au décor
en plastique et la fumée asphyxie
pratiquement sur place les danses les
pompiers interviendront pourtant très
vite mais il sera déjà trop tard rémy
roche
c'est la fumée qui a tué foudroyante
propager en quelques instants par le
système de ventilation immédiatement sur
place les pompiers n'ont mis qu'un quart
d'heure pour éteindre l'incendié mais il
était déjà trop tard
les victimes sont mortes asphyxiées sans
même avoir le temps de se précipiter
vers les issues
beaucoup d'entre elles ont été
retrouvées encore assise sur des
banquettes 130 personnes étaient dans la
discothèque lorsque le drame s'est
produit au milieu de la nuit vers 3h
molcard peut être un court circuit dans
les amplificateurs de l' orchestre qui
était en train de jouer au sous-sol et
c'est semble-t-il la combustion de
certains éléments de décoration qui a
produit la fumée mortels les éléments en
plastique ils seraient construits avec
des matériaux interdits
pourtant l'établissement avait subi
récemment plusieurs inspections
il paraissait donc en conformité avec
les règlements de sécurité très sévères
adoptées en espagne après l'incendié
d'une autre discothèque qui avait fait
90 morts à madrid
en 1983 le gouvernement de la province
d'aragon a décrété trois jours de deuil
en corse en revanche ce matin s'est
volontairement qu'un commando de l'ex
organisation nationaliste fnc a détruit
par explosif 70 bungalow d'un club de
vacances naturistes à l'ige de l'état en
haute corse la semaine dernière d'autres
installations touristiques avait été
plastiqué les indépendantistes s'en
prennent une nouvelle fois donc à ce
qu'ils estiment être la colonisation
touristiques étrangères de leurs pays
reporter richard mines
il était 8h30 ce matin lorsqu'un
commando d'une soixantaine d'hommes
masqués ont fait irruption dans le
village naturiste corsica la forêt à
linguizzetta à une soixantaine de
kilomètres au sud de bastia
là après avoir maîtrisé le gardien il
emmène une quinzaine de touristes
présents dans une pizzeria fermées en
cette période de l'année
parmi eux le docteur karl kaufmann le
gérant du camp durant plus d'une heure
le commando place minutieusement des
pains de plastique aux quatre coins du
village de vacances
à midi c'est l'explosion 30 de charges
éclate coup sur coup détruisant 70
bungalow sur les cent huit que compte le
camp cet après-midi le village de
cortina était zone interdite de
nombreuses charges n'ayant pas encore
explosé
les dégâts sont considérables
à l'échelle du risque pris par l'ex flnc
c'est la première fois que
l'organisation clandestine intervient
ainsi en plein jour
en fait le mouvement nationaliste
n'échappe pas aux contrecoups de la
trêve décidée par l'ex a fait l'insee en
juin 1988 durant plus d'un an les
nationalistes ont dû apprendre à exister
sans le bruit des bombes mais
l'impatience a grandi et depuis quelques
mois certains militants sont tentés par
une dissidence plus musclée en signant
son quatrième attentat
le flnc a voulu bien montrer qu'il
entendait conserver l'initiative à l'est
maintenant l' empire soviétique crack de
tous côtés à peine revenu démarche
frontières du nord de lituanie très
exactement monsieur gorbatchev se
retrouve face à l'état de guerre ou
presque au sud entre azéri et arménien
au centre du conflit souvenez-vous la
région à majorité arménienne chrétienne
du karabagh inséré dans la république
musulmane d'azerbaïdjan dans cette
région des affrontements se sont engagés
dit on alarme de guerre à bakou la
capitale aux herbes ajjan des
manifestations ont eu lieu hier faisant
plus d'une vingtaine de victimes annoncé
officiellement et erevan la capitale de
l'arménie soviétique on mobilise pour
porter secours aux au frère installé
dans la république et nuit bref tout est
rassemblé pour un affrontement
généralisé
les informations nous parviennent par
bris mais pour l'instant nous sommes
privés d'image d'actualité de ces deux
républiques interdit aux journalistes
étrangers
michel mompontet c'est à la fin d'une
manifestation comme celle-ci qu'une fois
de plus tout allait générer 150 mille
azéri réclamer le départ de tous les
arméniens du haut karabagh des slogans
ils sont dans la soirée passer aux actes
ouvrant la chasse aux arméniens l'armée
présente sur les lieux aurait très vite
été débordés par la violence de ce
groff les arméniens ont ce soir depuis
leur capital d revan décidé d'envoyer
des groupes d'autodéfense pour protéger
leurs compatriotes vivant dans le
haut-karabagh ce site où les azéris sont
armés ils ne disposaient il ya quelques
mois encore que de machettes et de
fusils leur armement a singulièrement
évolué ces derniers jours le haut
karabagh déchiré entre les airs et les
arméniens semble devenir un véritable
liban du caucase ce soir plus que jamais
les arméniens s'accroche à ce qu'ils
considèrent comme leur terre les azéri
eux sont prêts à tout pour les faire
partir prêt à tout même au massacre
les arméniens dispose d'une diaspora de
plusieurs millions de personnes dans le
monde qui se sont effectivement
immédiatement mobilisés après ces
annonces
en ce moment même une manifestation a
lieu devant l'ambassade du rss à paris
reporters thierry calmette jean-marc sur
ça les arméniens de paris réagissait
très vite ce soir aux nouvelles en
provenance d'azerbaïdjan
dès 18 heures 150 personnes environ ont
manifesté devant l'ambassade du rsa
objectif exiger la protection par
l'armée soviétique des minorités
arméniennes à becmil notamment certains
venaient juste de recevoir des nouvelles
très alarmante via l'arménie boulevard
mire kassoum of dans le quartier numéro
184 de bakou où plusieurs familles ont
été délogés de leur maison dénudée
emmené en voiture on ne sait où elles
ont disparu
ce qu'on sait aussi qu aujourd'hui à
midi sur le boulevard du front de mer
qu'est le boulevard primorsky nous
arméniens ce sont 12 arméniens sont
pendus chaque nouvelle sur des
programmes chaque rumeur augmentait
l'émotion et la colère des manifestants
certains arboraient les couleurs de
l'arménie ou proclamer leur attachement
à la barre où se dérouleraient
actuellement des combats entre azéri et
arménien
calme et dignité il n'y a eu aucun
incident avec les forces de l'ordre
restaient très discrets alors georges
bortoli on voit mal comment ce soir
l'union soviétique peut trouver une
solution dans cette région dont la
mesure où des deux côtés finalement lui
reproche son immobilisme et on lui
reproche
l'histoire de ces quarante dernières
années il ne s'est rien passé là bas il
ya deux facteurs de troupes qui
malheureusement s'additionnent il ya
d'une part cette hostilité entre deux
peuples voisins et même entremêlées les
azéri les arméniens avec vous l'avez dit
des milices d'autodéfense lourdement
armés qui se manifeste à la frontière
entre les deux républiques entre
l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie avec ces
affrontements maintenant quotidien haut
karabagh c'est à dire dans la région que
les deux pays se disputent et puis avec
ses ce dérapage grave non nous venons
d'entendre parler avec ces pogroms anti
arméniens qui semble avoir eu lieu à bas
coûts c'est à dire la capitale de
l'azerbaïdjan et dans la capitale de
l'azerbaïdjan il reste encore il reste
encore une communauté arménienne
maïs-grain exode massif donc quand je
disais que les deux peuples sont
entremêlées s'est tragiquement vrai mais
c'est le peuple qui s'affrontent
ils ont aussi à l'adversaire comme un
potentiel c'est-à-dire les russes les
russes que les azéri en particulier
considèrent de plus en plus clairement
comme des occupants comme des
colonisateurs
alors que tu peux faire moscou envoyer
des troupes supplémentaires pour séparer
les deux peuples qui s'affrontent
oui mais dans ce cas là la colère des
deux peuples risque de se retourner
contre moscou alors justement à
l'instant même d'autres dépêche tombe je
lis sur mon téléviseur que l'agent stahl
c'est à dire l'agencé officielle
soviétique annonce à l'instant qu'il y
aurait des dénombré des dizaines de
victimes azéri arménienne justement dans
la région du karabagh après un certain
nombre de combats qui auraient eu lieu
là bas ont fait état toujours selon
lagence soviétique tasse de quelques
milliers de combattants armés qui se
serait donc accroché aujourd'hui dans
cette région du karabagh et la situation
est vraiment grave puisque à l'instant
même georges vous me disiez que le
ministre de la défense soviétique qui
devait venir
en france cette semaine a décidé au
dernier moment d'ajourner son voyage à
pas autre événement à l'est après les
révolutions est venu le temps de la
réflexion des peuples qui ne veulent pas
être privés de leur victoire en bulgarie
comme en roumanie d'ailleurs la
population estime qu'il y à beaucoup
l'ancien parmi les nouveaux dirigeants
et cet après midi à sofia la capitale de
la bulgarie au pourtant les changements
se sont opérés en douceur par rapport à
la roumanie
une manifestation rassemblait plus de
50000 personnes réclamant l'accélération
des réformes reporter stéphane magnier
marcel martin l'image est cruel on le
fait c'est vulgaire n'enthousiasme la
ferveur qui illuminent les visages
il n'a jamais réussi à créer pire même
pour lui cette foule comme unis sur deux
mots d'ordre anti communiste supprimer
nos rôle dirigeant du parti
la constitution jugée tous les pourris
de l'ancien régime ces deux points
seront examinés dès demain par le
parlement lors de sa session
extraordinaire et dans deux jours tous
les orateurs se succèdent à la tribune
se retrouveront face aux membres du
parti pour discuter de l'avenir du débat
démocratique en bulgarie
alors aujourd'hui il leur fallait
absolument prouver leur représentativité
pour faire le poids dans les discussions
il y avait cinquante mille personnes à
ce meeting
objectif atteint
et puis voici péters vérone l'homme qui
est en train d'émerger comme leaders de
cette opposition et qui veut que le
début de liberté actuelle est beaucoup
plus loin ils sont convertis ce sens
notre intention de procéder le
développement pacifique sans dédé des
choses qui ont tué dans l'harmonie nous
voulons que la transfert du pouvoir
j'étais surtout se passe pacifiquement
et dans une esprit cultivé en fait une
évolution assez similaire la situation
rompait démocratique commence à échapper
au contrôle des anciens du régime qui on
le donne en mille il pourrait bien en
fait
en roumanie maintenant la télévision qui
fut le centre de la révolution du mois
de décembre a repris de son importance
hier soir on a montré d'abord le
deuxième fils de chaouchi secoue
valentin arrêté en compagnie de quelques
autres membres importants de l'ancienne
dictature valérie faune des images
attendu par tous en roumanie exige même
par la presse pour connaître enfin les
noms des hauts dignitaires du régime
ceaucescu arrêté ils sont cinq
présenté pour la première fois et sous
bonne garde le premier l'homme au bonnet
c'est valentin south et school fils aîné
du dictateur
on lui reproche d'avoir été membre du
comité du parti communiste et surtout
d'avoir dilapidé l'argent de papa qui
lui même l'avait volé au peuple
émile beau bout ensuite l'un des proches
de la famille accusé d'avoir encouragé
le génocide
two door poster nicoud ministre de
l'intérieur aurait donné l'ordre de
tirer sur la foule
marina go et chef de la garde
personnelle du south escou accusé de
s'être soumis au dictateur enfin doumit
troupeau bescou recteur de l'académie
politique accusé d'être un monument du
culte de la personnalité de chat ou
c'est ce coup on ne sait ni où ni quand
ce document diffusé hier soir la
télévision roumaine a été réalisé depuis
toujours à la télévision roumaine né
hier soir encore le président du conseil
de salut national monsieur enescu en
compagnie du premier ministre monsieur
petrus romanée
venu expliquer que la décision prise
vendredi soir sous la pression de la
foule de mettre hors la loi le parti
communiste roumain devait être revue ce
sera au peuple a dit le président par la
voie du référendum de se prononcer légal
entourant français à nos problèmes de
sociétés industrialisées au milieu de la
semaine qui vient de s'écouler le
premier ministre monsieur michel rocard
a annoncé qu'à partir du 1er avril
l'état ne participerait plus au
financement des caisses de retraite
complémentaire qui s'ajoutent aux
pensions de base de la sécurité sociale
pour les salariés il faut que les
partenaires sociaux négocient entre eux
at il dit réponse sur ce thème ce soir
de monsieur perrigault le président du
patronat au club de la presse de rop
supérieure entendra gouvernement dont
dix ont les prédécesseurs ont pris
contre notre avis formel la décision de
la retraite à 60 ans dire aujourd'hui
que c'était une décision qui
inéluctablement était voué à la faillite
moi ça me renverse moi je ne remets pas
en cause les engagements que gp pour
sept ans puis ce que je dis je suis prêt
à et continuer à les honorer et les
syndicats avec moi il n'y a aucune
raison que l'état ne continue pas je
crois cible et que maintenant chacun et
en ayant dit son point de vue le
gouvernement ayant dit que plus payer
nous ayant dit il faut continuer je
crois qu'il faut savoir étape et il faut
je m'excuse se poser la question de
savoir non pas à quel âge on peut
prendre sa retraite c'est pas le
problème je demande qu'un monsieur qu'un
homme qu'à travailleurs ou une femme
prenne sa retraite lorsqu'il aura
accumulé suffisamment de droits à la
retraite pour ne pas faire payer les
autres plus que normalement c'est tout
ce que je demande que certains là car
certains ça sera soit guéri gambie voilà
donc pour la vie de monsieur perrigault
il est vrai que les perspectives sont
assez inquiétantes dans ce domaine les
retraités vous savez peut-être profitent
de plus en plus longtemps de leur
retraite l'âge de s'être tête a donc été
avancé à 60 ans pour certains et le
nombre de cotisants actifs diminue
baisse de la natalité et puis le chômage
également alors la question
véritablement pose est la suivante
comment
[ __ ] les retraites aux alentours de
l'an 2000 reporter jacques violet
jean-louis bout c'est la retraite pour
beaucoup d'entre nous durera une
vingtaine d'années c'est-à-dire le quart
de la vie la france vieillit les
retraités sont aujourd'hui 10 millions
d'hommes et de femmes une population en
augmentation
où les inégalités sont frappantes des
comités départementaux de retraités ont
rédigé un cahier de doléances élaboré
dans 74 départements ce qu'ils
ressentent le plus mal c'est l'image du
retraité dans la société ont présenté
reprises et comme déjà en pauvre qu'il
faut absolument assister et tantôt comme
des gens qui sont les plus riches de
toute la france en lit les deux aussi
bien dans le même journal a deux faces
différentes ou bien les retraités sont
une masse épouvantable de gens qui
dépensent beaucoup d'argent et qui coûte
cher ou bien alors ce sont des gens qui
sont encore prêt et 10 tôt et qui vont
remplir toutes les fonctions de la
société qui ne sont pas remplies autre
point évoqué le problème des ressources
des retraités quelquefois liés à une
mauvaise préparation je pensais pouvoir
et à 60 ans mais c'est quand même face
aux six ans pour ses galons donc là vous
avez eu la surprise combien vous allez
toucher
combien je vais toucher pas énorme
4200 choix il y aura la complémentaire
forte heureusement un peu j'ai une quand
même une aussi au privé la provence et
ce frère et que je règle c'est le régime
général de sécurité sociale qui a su en
la retraite de base versée par la caisse
nationale de l'assurance vieillesse
nous avons actuellement titre du régime
général 7 million de prestataires auquel
nous avons payé pour l'année 89 nous
aurons payé par les 89
environ 200 milliards de prestations ya
200 milliards c'est l'équivalent du
chiffre d'affaires de la régie renault
ce sont les cotisations des salariés
actifs qui sont immédiatement est
presque intégralement reversés aux
retraités c'est ce système de
répartition qui fait dire à certains
qu'en 2010 les actifs ne pourront plus
payer pour les retraités aux retraites
de base il faut ajouter les différents
régimes complémentaires
depuis la mise en place de la retraite à
60 ans 83 le gouvernement subventionner
une partie du surcoût des régimes
complémentaires
aujourd'hui il ne veut plus payer et
demande aux partenaires sociaux de tout
prendre en charge les patrons
s'ils ne remettent pas en cause le
principe de la retraite à 60 ans exige
une durée d'activité plus longue
est ce qu'il faudra demain retarder
l'âge de la retraite ou réduire le
montant des pensions versées
c'est l'objet des futures négociations
un autre problème de société dans un
pays où la voiture est reine la france
en l'occurrence l'information n'est pas
mince en effet un récent sondage
effectué par la sofres pour un magazine
spécialisé auto moto révèle qu'une
majorité de français 60% ce n'est pas
rien on peur des poids lourds sur les
routes et autoroutes
il faut dire qu'on est loin du temps où
l'on considérait comme sympa les
chauffeurs de poids lourds le trafic a
pris de telles proportions qu'ils sont
partout à toute heure
leur mentalité également changé du même
coup et ils sont à l'origine de plus en
plus d'accidents mortels reporter marque
maisonneuve philippe du mali
en france les poids lourds sont
responsables de 16% des victimes de la
route
pourtant il ne couvre que 7% du
kilométrage parcouru par la totalité des
véhicules circulant sur le territoire
français
le déclin du transport ferroviaire la
baisse terrible du trafic fluvial tout
contribue à l'hégémonie des routiers une
hégémonie tiens qui est la majorité des
autres usagers parce que la moitié des
accidents mortels sur autoroute sont dus
à la présence d'un point d'eau ce qui
marque les usagers c'est que l'accident
poids lourds est beaucoup plus grave que
l'accident de voiture légère à cause du
poids de la masse du collège au centre
de rosny sous bois on sait aussi que
plus la taille du poids lourds augmente
plus le nombre d'accidents qu'il cause
augmente il y a des gens qui n'ont
jamais de l'accident il y en a tant la
malchance ayant dre cela on ne veut pas
défendre où il ya une systématisation et
répétition d'incidents dus à des
imprudences au sein de la fntr le très
puissant syndicat patronal on ne nie pas
la part de responsabilité des chauffeurs
mais on reconnaît aussi que la faible
taille des entreprises renforce le
pouvoir du patron et qu'il est difficile
pour le chauffeur de respecter la
réglementation
vous paraît le plus pénible accumulé des
heures jusqu'à 6 heures
celui qui donne les ordres à toc
chargement déchargement pourquoi on va
se lever pour faire des envois grondona
goodman chargé à l'idée où on devrait
dormir seul a dû au mauvais temps par
jour du travail est répandu jours les
journées du joueur pour ce mois pourtant
la réglementation est stricte tue pas
plus de quatre heures et demie de
conduite d'affilée à plus de 50 heures
de travail par semaine mais 70% des
marchandises sont transportées par la
route les denrées sont souvent
périssables on ne constituent pas de
stock dans les magasins
il faut donc faire vite très vite même
si au volant on prend des risques pour
soi et pour les autres séquences
inattendue il ne manque pas d'idées le
curé de la paroisse de la trinité à
paris dans le quartier chaud pigalle
clichy s'est installée restaurateurs
avec l'aide de bénévoles d'une
association de secours aux plus démunis
dans son établissement et mais il
accueille tout le monde sans distinction
des gens seuls dépôts mais comme on dit
de la grande ville font un prix tout à
fait modique et toute référence publique
mise à part il leur offre de partager le
pain et le reporter
valérie fournier et philippe et elle en
trouvait
en magasin monsieur le curé de la
paroisse de la trinité a décidé
d'étendre son sacerdoce au quartier le
plus démuni moralement de paris pigalle
un quartier chaud chaud devant et dans
les cuisines poireaux vinaigrette
entrecôte grillée
tout comme dans un vrai restaurant et
pour le même prix les dix commandements
le café et l'addition
jésus est venu pour sauver son dogme et
notamment ceux qui ont le plus besoin il
n'est pas venu simplement pour les bien
portants
il n'est pas normal que des prêts qui
sont des serviteurs de dieu et c'est
d'être présent des gens qui ont de joie
de vous c'est une mission c'est aussi
aux missions bien sûr c'est pas
uniquement pour le plaisir la vaisselle
dans les salles etc l'idée principale
tout le monde se côtoie de la dame
patronnesse en partance pour lourdes à
la jeune femme en rupture de foyers sans
oublier les petits truands du milieu qui
viennent goûter au pain du ciel à bon
compte
c'est un peu une famille c'est très
mélangées et donc chacun peut se sentir
tranquille et sans se dire c'est pas
pour moi c'est pour nous et je crois que
au même table le langage des discussions
entre les personnes qui ne se seraient
jamais rencontrés dans le cadre même en
dehors de l'église
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est quoi en
tout temps de nous en servir
il ya des gens qui sont dans la chapelle
au dessus et qui prie et pour nous c'est
très important et ça nous aide
énormément car il ne faut pas oublier
que nous sommes ici c'est assez
classique dans ce quartier de paris dans
un bar montant mais là chaque marche
nous rapproche du seigneur après sa
tournée le pêcheur des âmes en rade
retourne vers son église
loin de ces drôles de paroissiens où il
rompra là aussi le pain et servira le
vin
séquence mère maintenant le plus grands
voiliers du monde cinq mâts entièrement
construit en france au chantier naval du
havre a quitté son port d'attache cet
après midi direction le soleil des
caraïbes son nom le club med
l'entreprise de vacances mondialement
connue l'a conçu comme un véritable
village flottant gentil reporter patrice
pollet frédéric basque
trois ans pour le construire des
milliers d'heures de travail une
quantité impressionnante de problèmes à
résoudre mais au bout du compte le plus
grand voilier du monde est 100% français
à 14h cet après midi les dix mille
tonnes de ce géant à voile se sépare du
cac direction les caraïbes
mais le commandant lambert donne ses
premières instructions
ça fait longtemps qu'elle voyait pas
sortir avant tout voilà c'est fait ça
ordinaire sont achetés et on peut tout
accomplir un défi pendant ce temps
branle bas de combat aux cuisines
production immédiates il faut faire vite
les premiers invités sont déjà à table
ce soir ils seront peut-être jouer au
casino pour ensuite se détendre sur le
pont oui je sais que c'est un bateau qui
fabuleux
on m'avait dit qu'il était beau je crois
qu'ils ont tort puisque la 187 mètres de
long 4 120 passagers 20 mètres de large
il a marché aux essais à plus longue
venu à la voile 22 km heure de 1500
mètres carrés de voile est un système
anti roulis qui empêchera les passagers
d'avoir le mal de mer avec ce bateau la
nouvelle marine à voile française trace
sa route
loin devant ses concurrents elle fait ce
soir bien des jaloux
voilà et en gagnant au trc vous pourrez
peut-être vous payer des vacances sur ce
bateau pour gagner aujourd'hui il
fallait jouer le 11 le 3 et le 9 et pour
ce qui concerne le quarté + et bien
ajouter le 18 et vous gagnez un peu plus
de 42 millions voilà ce journal est
terminée tout après les prévisions météo
jose dans la pierre le dernier journal
de philippe gassot aux alentours de
23h45 bonsoir bonne soirée sur notre
chaîne à samedi prochain
oh